le coup de départ n'a pas été donnée
mais les coureurs sont des gens puisses
tu veux mais tu es le jour j dans un
rassemblement à louiseville en mauricie
la chef libéral dominique anglade a
dévoilé l'identité de son président de
campagne l'ex ministre des finances
carlos leitao carlos est la personne
toute indiquée pour être président de
cette campagne si
elle compte sur lui pour combattre
l'inflation il le fera des lignes de
côtés puisqu'il a décidé de ne pas se
porter candidat cette fois ci surtout
maintenant un voyage tous âges de départ
d'une campagne électorale va s'gêner aux
vraies saveurs mais ça manque un peu
mais je vais être très actif pendant la
campagne moi ce que je vois c'est que
les gens sont vraiment insatisfait de la
gestion du gouvernement par rapport au
coût de la vie
à montréal où il se présente le chef du
parti québécois c'est plutôt dit
préoccupé lui par l'avenir du français
et par la violence armée je veux pas que
montréal devienne un bal témoins je veux
que montréal demeure ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire une ville francophone est
une ville sécuritaire mais tous les
adversaires de la coalition avenir
québec s'entendent pour dire que rien
n'est joué mais moi je pense qu'on va
surprendre agréablement
les candidats ou des candidates de la
caq se sont fait promettre une limousine
qui sont entrés de magazines et de celle
d'un siège chauffant dans cette
limousine là ici vous avez que des gens
de conviction
d'ailleurs le chef du parti conservateur
a poursuivi sa route en beauce il a
lancé sa campagne la semaine dernière
quand l'instant alors nos adversaires y
attendre que legault le donne legault
band on attend qu après le go oo
là encore le message est clair tout peut
arriver on veut pas être premier au jour
où on veut être premier au dernier jour
de la campagne électorale le pouvoir
[Applaudissements]